hello everyone and welcome back to
another very nice game from defeated
online world corporate championship uh
where different companies are facing
each other and
some of them have extremely strong
players like we've seen the previous one
uh where
magnus carlsen was uh was playing for
his kindred group here we have
janipomnich versus uh pavel
anisimov uh and both of them are very
strong russian grandmasters however
even though they they are both very
strong nepo is some 200 over 250
rating points higher rated now what uh
does that mean
in terms of actual moves uh well let's
let's uh check out
what was played in this game and see and
usually when you have such a drastic uh
difference in rating
games tend to be uh pretty crazy but
sometimes
sometimes the the player with um with a
lesser rating uh can really really
surprise and then you know
completely crush a super grand master
and even though if you are new to chess
uh there is no such title as super grand
master super grand master is something
that we
uh call someone who is maybe 220 750 and
higher and with nipple being almost
almost 2800 i don't know some 27 89 uh
he definitely
is a super master in those terms because
it was a long long time ago when the the
grand master title was uh first awarded
and then you needed a 250 elo rating
points but nowadays uh the elo
ratings are much much higher so they are
there are
a lot of grandmasters basically uh so
let's check out the game
uh and see what happens here so nipple
with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh and uh anismo goes
for e6 so uh he goes for the french
defense and nipple not being a stranger
to the french himself he employed it
even in the candidates tournament
and played some very nice games uh in
the french
we have d4 d5 and now knight to c3
defending the e4 pawn we have d captures
knight captures and now
knight to d7 going for the blackburn
defense of the rubinstein variation
knight to f3 and now knight g to f6 so
nicely developing nipple trades ones we
have captures captures and now
knight to e5 the so-called capoblanca
move
uh we have knight back to d7 now
offering a trade of yet another pair of
knights and here
uh there are a couple of moves that were
played the most famous one is bishop to
f4
uh team of have played it against the
dingler and in the 2009 match between uh
russia and china and the dean was able
to win that game with black but here we
have
knight to c4 so here nipple avoids the
trade and it is
already as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game
so he wants to keep a bit more material
on the board and
surprise his opponent a little bit so
knight back to f6 the knights are not
getting traded so the knight
retreats to a more active square bishop
to f4
continuing development and now bishop to
e7 black now wants the castle with
bishop to e5
now that this knight is gone the bishop
can stay there
can't really be challenged unless black
wants to waste another tempo
but for the moment that's impossible
because the g pawn would hang so here we
have castles and
bishop to d3 and now by avoiding this
trait of knights
nipple now has a nicely placed bishop
pair here the queen can easily
enter the game and it's it's still a
question whether white will castle
kingside or queenside but
chances are as the attacking formation
is uh
present here uh it will be a queenside
castle but there's still the question of
this knight uh
what to do with it and black makes it
easy black immediately attacks it with
b5
and apple just brings it back with
knight to e3 and now
c5 striking in the center and black
claims that he is now
very happy uh by uh by this uh central
push although it's a it's a very
dangerous push because white can capture
on c5
uh without black being able to recapture
it's uh it's very dangerous because if
you go for something like bishop
captures on c5
then a lot of moves are possible there's
a queen to f3
uh just going after uh this rook here so
uh you could do a lot of things you
could do bishop captures on f6 and after
queen captures a queen to h5
now threatening checkmate also going for
that bishop on c5 and okay you can play
bishop to b
for check then you can block with c3 and
then for example
g6 pushing back the queen but then queen
captures on b5
and it's a it's a very fun game but this
is probably something like this is
probably what black wanted he wanted to
give up some material to get an
active play but nipple ignores it after
the c5 he goes queen to f3
now puts pressure on the rook and black
needs to react to this so first
c captures on d4 uh anisimov sacrifices
the exchange and it would be
very interesting if the rook is captured
but nipple is not
interested he just plays queen side
castles uh
and now offers uh even more material so
what's the idea why is the
knight being offered now now well it's a
very uh
it's very tricky because now if captured
there's bishop captures on h7
and you might think but that's a lot of
pieces to give up for the queen yes but
your rook is still hanging and after
captures captures and captures
black has so many pieces but the rook is
still hanging and once white captures
that then white has just
en enough of a winning material
advantage even if you
gain the past pawn with this it doesn't
really matter queen captures you're
gonna
pick that up it's not a problem so after
this queenside castle we have queen to
a5
now again with some threats of queen
captures on a2
uh and again offering that rook on a8 so
can the rook on a8 be captured now
well let's see what happens if you do if
you capture an a8 uh you get
d captures on e3 now closing off the d2
square and now you're uh
you you are being threatened so what can
you do here
if you go for bishop captures an f6
first queen captures an a2
threatens checkmate and now you have to
waste the move to capture here
f captures an e3 now bishop captures an
on f6 and it's
again a very dangerous position to be in
for white
uh you have to defend this somehow
probably c3 blocking this and now also
the bishop can help out
with the defense here but none of this
happened as
uh after this um uh after this queen to
a5 move attacking the a2 point nepo just
played bishop captures on d4
uh and this is a this is different now
because the b2 pawn is already defended
and capturing an a2 doesn't
yield any results queen captures an a8
is now winning for white
now after for example queen day one
check it doesn't really matter king to
d2 and there's no good move here
if you go queen to a5 check c3 just
blocking check
you're up so much material it's
completely winning for white
so instead after bishop captures on d4
we have bishop the a6
now developing and also now the rooks
are connected
one defending the other uh and now
nipple goes for the attack
knight the g4 and now he's trying to
remove one of the defenders
of the king side then the bishop player
will definitely become fully operational
and now we have to see can black finally
capture this a2 pawn or not what is uh
the
this knight the g4 move even changing
well the problem now with queen captures
on a2
is that you can just capture with check
and after bishop captures you're gonna
capture with the bishop now you're down
a piece you have to
recapture and after g captures queen
captures uh yes it seems like
now black uh can start delivering some
checks but after queen a1 check there's
really not much to do
king to the uh king to d2 the queen is
once again defending the b2 pawn and
after
you deliver one check c3 and it's it's
looking very dangerous for example you
can go rook f to d8 uh put some pressure
along the d
file now threaten b4 to open up the the
light square bishop but just b4
and white is very happy here if queen to
80 check even king to e3
so quite a quite a crazy line if rook to
d5
uh trying to get the other rook into the
game now you start h4
and although a very very dangerous
looking white is simply
white is simply much better here you can
go rook h3 to g3 that's game over you
can play h5
h6 that's also game over so uh
a lot a lot to consider here so even
though it looks
uh like you could do it you you actually
can so here first we have knight
captures on g4
queen captures on g4 now threatening
checkmate and now
finally g6 and only now that black
wasted a move uh to prevent checkmate
only now nipple goes with king to b1
defending the a2 pawn
so here b4 uh now offering a trade of
light square bishops here and
nipple captures it is the way to go we
have captures captures
uh and now h4 now preparing to open up
the h file with h5 and h captures and g6
so black prevents this we have h5 and
now
queen to f4 here nipple makes room for
the g pawn to march forward and then he
wants to open up the position
so queen to b5 now queen also helps out
with the defense of the fifth rank and
maybe
just maybe black will have enough time
to maybe start pushing his a pawn but
it's a it's a long way to go so here
nepal continues we have g4
and now rook a to d8 abandoning any idea
so of pushing the a pawn
with rook eight to d8 and now comes
queen to h6
and this is uh this is a pretty uh
pretty great move for white because now
uh it's a very questionable what do you
even play here for black
uh the the absolute best is rook
captures on d4 and then after rook
captures on d4 i mean you have to do
something
as checkmate is being threatened so uh
rook captures is is the way to go you
play rook captures and then you shift
the bishop over here bishop to f6 you
can use it for defensive purposes but
also for attacking purposes
and even though white is better here it
was the move
if you were to prolong the game because
it's like i said it's a rapid game it's
a 10 minute game
so better to survive as long as possible
but here anismo
played e5 and although this blocks
checkmate momentarily
uh it blunders the game uh in a
different way because now white's attack
is
unstoppable so feel free to pause the
video here and win the game for nipple
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not doing
anything weird like moving the bishop
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
uh g captures an h5 this is the only
winning move
and now uh black really is in trouble
and
there's not much you can do if you
capture an h5 it's just game over rook
h1 check
rook you want check and there's nothing
to do you can block with the bishop and
then rook captures his checkmate
so obviously after g captures an h5 you
have to try something else
uh an anisimov played rook captures on
d4
but it's uh simply not enough h captures
on g6 now threatening checkmate
uh we have rook capture sunday one with
check trading off a pair of rooks first
to get the other rook away from the h
file but now f captures on g6 but now
uh the white queen can do whatever the
white queen wants as the king is
pretty much helpless so we'll be able to
only go back and forth so here queen
captures and g6 with check
king to h8 and now rook the g1 there are
a lot of winning ideas here rook the g1
is only one of them
and it was in this position on move 28
that uh
uh pavel anismo resigned in the game and
uh a very nice victory for yanni
pomnishi
uh you resigned because there's no
defense uh this is checkmate
this is check maybe this is checkmate
well
all of this is checkmate and there's
really no no uh
there's no move that even prolongs mate
like uh unless you want to play
something like
queen to f1 uh sorry about missing so
many errors but for some reason
chess.com decided that it was
important to be able to do this arrow i
have no idea why but
um you know it's it is pretty weird
you couldn't do that like uh when uh
when they were starting out
uh but yeah yeah i just said chess is
weird like that sometimes
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as you've seen
um uh it's not as if uh
nipple just completely obliterated uh
pavel uh
even though he is over 250 rating points
higher rated but it was uh
it was a very clean game and in 28 moves
that's uh
well in today's age uh you know in 2021
uh this can definitely be considered
even a miniature uh because you know in
morphe zera
you know games up to 15 moves maybe 20
moves were considered miniatures but
nowadays with the
uh you know uh the use of engines and
everyone has
all the lines prepared up to move 20 uh
we we have to consider a miniature
anything
maybe even below 30 moves but it's up
for discussion definitely
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
uh enjoyed it uh
try using hashtag suggestion if you have
some of your own favorite games here
because it's impossible for me to go
through all of them but if you you know
stumble upon a great one do share it i
will definitely show it
so yeah once again thank you all for
watching i would like to thank franco
moore
lynn herbert uh james bosley michael
salviani and david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
one of the suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day